so roughly five months after fedmeister
a former member of the offline tv
content house was accused of sexual
misconduct by multiple people
his 25-page response to those
allegations was posted to twitter
the only problem is fed never wanted
that document to be made
public and according to him someone he
trusted leaked it to social media
in it he not only apologizes for his
actions but he levels
new accusations at pokemon and so
naturally
this caused a giant mess online
[Music]
guys we are moving closer and closer to
2 million subscribers but we need your
help to get there
all i need you to do it's really quite
simple is scroll down
and hit that subscribe button all right
so all the drama that we're talking
about today
popped off when a 25-page document
written by fedmeister
was dropped in our laps on wednesday
afternoon the catch here is that he
never wanted the document to be made
public and in a statement he made after
it was released
he says that somebody he trusted
actually leaked it to social media
but before we go any further there's a
bunch of context i have to give you
for all of this to make sense so let's
rewind
five months back in late june twitch
experienced a wave of sexual misconduct
and sexual assault allegations
which we reported on over the past few
weeks there have been more than 300
allegations
of sexual assault and sexual misconduct
against members of the esports gaming
and streaming world
and one of the situations that we talked
about involved twitch streamer
fedmeister who was once a member of
offline tv
now multiple members of the offline tv
house accused him of sexual misconduct
with the original allegation
coming from another streamer in the
house named yvonne she posted a twitter
alleging that fed came into a room in
the middle of the night multiple times
and inappropriately touched her as a
result of these allegations
fed was removed from both the offline tv
content house
and from the company itself following
the announcement that offline tv had
removed
fed pokeman shared her perspective on
the situation on stream
i felt a growing distance between me
and the people within offline tv and
also the people within our
greater friend circle this was
coincidental with the time that
everybody was also becoming a lot closer
to fed
not long after that fed tweeted out this
apology and then pretty much went dark
he wasn't streaming and he wasn't active
on social media
now it's important to talk about fed and
pokeman before we move on
because their relationship takes up a
large portion of that leaked document
that i mentioned earlier
in the video that we just showed you
pokeman talks about how she eventually
had to clarify to fed that
despite their close relationship they
were only ever just going to be friends
she also alleges that fed told other
people that they were quote
seeing each other when they weren't he
tried to isolate her from other otb
members by spreading rumors
and generally just caused distrust
amongst the friend group
he would lie about me a lot create
create
narratives in his favor and insinuate a
lot of negative things
which drove everyone around me away from
me
and finally pokeman discussed how fed
would talk negatively about yvonne how
she does nothing to help otv
and that they should kick her out of the
house this last bit is important because
again it comes up in the leaked document
that i mentioned earlier
he would talk to me about how yvonne was
lazy and not working enough and playing
league all the time
and i was concerned and he would say oh
she like won't work on no tv stuff with
me or brainstorm and blah blah blah
this discussion
got to the point of us almost letting
yvonne go
from the company which brings us back
around to wednesday november 25th which
was when his 25 page response to those
allegations was leaked online now a lot
of that document is your garden variety
twit longer apology
and a lot of it focuses on the
relationship between him and pokemon
quote i have already apologized to
yvonne and lily privately
and this statement will in no way
contradict their stories
instead the purpose is to address the
individuals that i believe are twisting
the truth for their own benefit
from my own health i can no longer stay
silent end quote
now i'm not going to go over all 25
pages because honestly nobody's got time
for that
but i will highlight portions where he
talks about his and pokeman's
relationship
because it's here where things get
really messy fed basically says that
while he did make mistakes
quote watching pokey talk about all the
things i've done with
little to zero context about our
relationship hurt me pretty bad
end quote from there fed writes quote i
definitely did some questionable things
and broke her trust
but there are some claims she makes
about me and herself that are either
false twisting the truth or misconstrued
end quote he also says that it was
actually pokemane and not him
who wanted yvonne fired with the
documents showing screenshotted text
messages from her as proof
the rest of the document includes things
like a section on edc
2018 where he told the guy that pokey
was interested in
that quote there's something going on
end quote between them
which made her upset a section on what
he saw as repeated patterns of behavior
in their relationship
that caused him to feel frustrated and
led on a section where he tells a second
guy who he didn't realize pokey was into
that yeah quote there's something going
on between us
end quote on top of all that there's a
section on the aftermath of the
intervention that members of the offline
tv held for him
in it he talks about writing multiple
drafts of a statement that never saw the
light of day
because of a situation he describes as
quote a really bad game of telephone
end quote really this whole fed pokeman
situation comes down to two people
saying that they were manipulated by the
other
and of course because these two people
are incredibly popular personalities
thousands of people were following the
situation as it unfolded
live stream fails was inundated with
clips of streamers like destiny reading
through and reacting to the document
people making wild speculations and
generally
[ __ ] on pokemon i'm sorry she's just
lying right now
oh no she needed way better lies for
this
these are bad lies you just have to read
the text messages
these messages that she's sending are
not reading like somebody like man you
know yvonne after you know you guys
inappropriately had that thing
you know yvonne really seems like she's
compromised and she said that's not what
her texts read like at
all that is just not true now eventually
pokeman jumped on stream and addressed
each section of the document and fed's
response
she reiterated that she only ever wanted
to be friends cold
steve essentially that we were a thing
long after i had this conversation with
him
about i just want to be friends she
talked about how this drama with fed is
nothing more than quote a bunch of
regular 20 year old relationship
[ __ ] end quote and how it's
irrelevant compared to the initial
sexual misconduct allegations
all of this is really not all that
important it's regular
20 year old relationship [ __ ] he
said she said blah blah blah you know
nothing that important happened in my
opinion what i shared about the steve
situation is my honest truth
and i feel like it is just really
irrelevant in comparison to
the incident that actually triggered all
of this
and in a pretty heated moment pokeman
talked about how
while she didn't handle this situation
perfectly
nobody was meant to see all of this
because this was a personal situation
between her and fed
i really like i just don't know what to
say did i i didn't handle it perfectly
i'm sorry and i'm sorry you guys have to
read and learn about this cringy [ __ ]
but like you're not meant to because
you're never in my shoes you were never
in his shoes
you were never a third person observer
now in a statement he released after the
initial 25 page document was leaked
online fed says that he wrote all of
this
shortly after the accusations were made
quote i was encouraged by my friends to
write out my side of things
however i did it while feeling extremely
vindictive as i felt that someone i had
once deeply cared for
inaccurately spoke out against me to
this day
i do believe that i was mischaracterized
however after talking to pokey
i came to understand her perspective and
decision making
end quote now we're at a bit of an
impasse at the moment with a lot of he
said she said going on about a personal
situation
both people probably just want to put
behind them and
honestly we should let them
this this figurine of me that i got
had me thinking
how am i narcissist listen i got this
for free based off a article that i
wrote
which i'm not gonna [ __ ] talk about
it here because it's long-winded story
never mind what this got me thinking
about was that movie toy soldiers
god it's so dangerous when you think
that's not fair i i forget the uh
chewbacca looking dude's name but
um he was my favorite and like that
that all-out war that they had at the
end which is fantastic that
but i need to go back and watch this
movie now because wow your description
is so
visceral i i can't can barely hold my
excitement to be wrong why the [ __ ] am i
still holding this up
because you're you love your having your
little friend
to talk to
all right i'm done